estoy en los ejercicios sobre el mapeo
de figuras de la canacar de mí y me dice
mapear el cuadrilátero movible al
cuadrilátero a psd con transformaciones
rígidas aquí en azul tengo este
cuadrilátero móvil y lo quiero mapear
sobre este cuadrilátero gris usando
estos tres botones aquí tengo los
botones de las transformaciones rígidas
es decir trasladar rotar y reflejar y
por supuesto también tengo el botón de
deshacer esto en las herramientas de
lacan academy la técnica que voy a
utilizar es primero trasladar para
lograr que uno de los puntos
correspondientes en ambos cuadriláteros
se superponga por ejemplo parece que se
apretó aquí en el botón de trasladar
observan aparecen estos puntos de aquí y
parece que este punto corresponde a ce
por lo tanto voy a trasladar este punto
a su correspondiente punto original
observa que el apretar el botón puede
trasladar la figura de una manera
sencilla trasladarla hasta aquí donde el
punto ce y su imagen coinciden ahora
veamos para que estos dos puntos se
superpongan aquí es decir el lado cede
me quedé con su imagen arriba parece que
bueno ya no necesitamos más traslación
es ya que tenemos un punto que se
superpone a su imagen y ahora que usamos
rotar o reflejar bueno a primera vista
parece que necesitamos una rotación
intentemos hacer la rotación para que
este segmento de aquí se superponga con
el lado cede así que voy a ponerle a
rotar ok y ahora observa voy a rotar de
tal manera que si de hecho esta de la
herramienta ya está perfectamente de
mapeado así que muy bien resultó hicimos
una rotación y lo hemos logrado ok vamos
a hacer
esta vez que necesitamos
intentaré usar la misma técnica parece
que este punto de aquí y el punto se
coinciden por lo tanto voy a trasladar
mi figura hasta que esos dos puntos
coincidan vamos a trasladar la figura
hasta que estos dos puntos coincidan
perfecto justo aquí y ahora algo
interesante está pasando porque solo con
trasladar coinciden los puntos cm y los
puntos a y ahora parece que rotar no me
ayudaría mucho porque entonces se
moverían los puntos que son la imagen de
amd y la imagen de ser así que lo mejor
va a ser reflejar vamos a reflejar y
para ello vamos a utilizar la recta que
contiene a up ya c
primero ponemos la recta sobre la cual
haremos la reflexión muy bien aquí es la
recta que tienen aa yace y después
reflejamos con este eje muy bien
lo hemos logrado la idea del por qué
reflejamos sobre esta recta que contiene
ya se es porque la recta que contiene a
amd ya sem y sus imágenes después de la
transformación deben de seguir en el
mismo sitio por lo tanto esta es una
buena pista de que en una reflexión
debemos de reflejar sobre una recta que
contenga los puntos que queremos dejar
inmóviles así que hemos acabado en este
segundo ejercicio hicimos una traslación
y una reflexión y acabamos hasta la
próxima